she would always say that I'll pick
someone for you and if you ever I guess
find someone for yourself I won't accept
especially if it's outside of the
culture my mom will eventually agree
yeah yeah I'm not going to leave someone
who's really good a good Muslim um to
agree with my mom it's like when your
mom gives you an ultimate yeah Mom or a
girl a girl says to you your mom or your
or me what are we are we bengalis are we
Bali Muslims are we Muslims do you see I
make them think critically and then
realize what we're actually fing a lot
of Hindu culture so what my mom would
say is I gave birth to you and I raised
you so you have to marry I choose and if
you don't then I don't accept the moment
of Eid when we're supposed to bow down
and like touch her feet we said no
actually I'm not going to do it she got
so offended so offended who got offended
my mom and I was I'm looking to get
married basically so I went and you know
what he said to me he go no this is only
for B I spoke to my mom can I Mar
outside my ethnicity as long as they're
Muslim mom said she'd prefer a Bengali
girl purely because she can't speak
English yeah speaking about emotional
blackmail speak about pressurizing they
will tell you you get married again
you're going to be disowned you rejected
it because you're too concerned about
what others will think it's good as
seeing Allah or the community community
I I just don't believe that South Asian
men have the ability to treat each
wife what we go for is if the skin color
it's nothing to do racism whoever's the
lightest they r I know know
but they think he's actually in the
wrong like she wouldn't understand that
she would be like just very just
tolerate it don't ever like come to a
point of like divorce cuz what are
people going to
say brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing de that you want to do but
we turn it into a moneymaking machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of true s AAR I
myself will be donating for that
inshallah click the link below and
donate may Allah subhana bless and
preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well in
welcome to another episode of The Bitter
truth show um as you guys know we're
doing a cultural episode we've had the
somalis um may Allah bless them inshah
we've got to know a lot about the Somali
culture uh from their weddings to the
divorce to marital disputes uh and we're
doing the same thing same format same
questions and today we have our balii
brothers and sisters um the only thing I
know is a Balan that's what I know
B yeah that's that's what I know B what
is
it what does that mean that means I'm
good oh yeah so someone says Bal to me I
say if someone says Bal to me what do I
say Bal Bal Bal yeah that means I'm good
what if I say what if I say Bala Bala
what does that mean good good good good
and that's exactly I am good inshah that
doesn't make sense good good me I never
make sense anyways uh so guys inshah
before I start want to praise Allah
subhana T the most merciful the most
just all Praises glory and gratitude
belong to him um we've done this episode
with the team you know we decided and U
you know with the co-producer which is
my wife you know she GRS me sometimes
but I think I deserve it uh but yeah
before we do culture episode get to know
different cultures and yeah if you're
watching this we want you guys to come
as well your Nigerian congales Jamaican
English Turkish Kurdish whatever in
please apply it's not a debate we're
just here to just to get to know your
coaching and not show uh please tell us
a bit about yourselves and then we'll
get straight into the topic I will ask
the first question and let's see what
we're going to in find out about the
Bali I'm sry I'm just a YouTuber uh
react to YouTube videos it really can
you guys please speak to your mic loud
and I'm a property rent at properties
that's it Mah may Allah bless you
[Music]
insh uh my name is mahi I'm I'll work in
finance and I do a few side projects as
well all right is this uhum I'm Ki uh I
do YouTube on the side and controversial
topics Salam alikum I'm Pina if you
didn't know I'm her sister we're blood
sisters we don't look like like we don't
look like sisters and
um um yeah that's it do do you study you
work sister um So currently I'm
unemployed but I'm working on a vision
that's
it
asalam alikum my name is Hal Yasmin I'm
26 and Architectural
design may Allah bless our honorable
sisters for being here and our honorable
Brothers we going to get straight into
the topic uh the first question you
usually ask in these topics as well
inshah is
that I have some experience with a buali
coach a little bit when I was looking to
get married there was a from actually I
was saying to off marriage that didn't
work out come to that to a bit later on
about when it comes to marrying outside
uh outside inah but um the first topic
is basically as Bolis yeah when it comes
to seeking marriage so for example you
want to get married yeah how do you go
about so what does the culture say does
it say that it's arranged marriage we
find someone for you you can go find
somebody come and talk to us about it
please tell me in a not sh in your
culture if you want to get married how
how do how do you guys go about it it in
a nutsh if that that is that clear yeah
yes let's start off with the sisters if
if you yeah um so I know culturally like
we
obviously uh I guess the the groom come
comes over to the the woman's house and
asks for hand in marriage but like
specifically speaking in my house my mom
she wouldn't she would always say that
I'll pick someone for you uh and if you
ever I guess find someone for yourself I
won't accept especially if it's outside
of the
culture okay so so would you say that
for
example it's mainly arrange marriage
yeah yeah what I would add to that
is I feel like it's very different in
every Bengali household um we're not the
same and we don't have the same parents
um so it really depends on like their
mindset
and uh the mother
the Family itself single parent
household we don't have a father as well
so yeah we don't really have a Mah so so
for someone to like come to so it's a
bit difficult in that way yeah to speak
in a subjective way is if we let's say I
found someone from the African culture
um and I really like him he's Muslim and
he's practicing and
everything this is a bit controversial
but I would I would matter what I'd
still go with that marriage um my mom
will eventually agree yeah yeah um I'm
not going
to leave someone who's really good a
good Muslim um to agree with my mom yeah
my mom she regardless she wouldn't agree
to any of them okay so what we're going
to do is we're going to come to the the
Maring outside your culture we're going
to come to that but when it comes to
thank you we can elaborate on that no no
no no is just for example as a young
Bali person looking to get married does
parents say listen don't be thinking
that you're going to find somebody Etc
no we are going to find someone so is it
like to you you're like okay you know
what there's no point in me if I saw a
brother that I like or whatever is is it
like from the get-go like what my mom
says is that how he works I just want to
know say something so I think generally
with like Bengali marriages there's two
approaches there's a traditional
approach and a modern approach so the
traditional approach is you tell your
parents I'm I want to get married I'm
old enough now financially secure Etc so
at that point your parents
will most likely speak to their brothers
sisters friends um to find someone who
could match what you're looking for but
I I'd say more more often than not
there's a modern approach where people
go and find their like spouses
themselves so through apps meeting
friends or friends so there there's two
different approaches basically
traditionally plan It's usually the
moment you say you know what I want to
get married your family would tell you
that we're going to look for you do they
do they ask you what you're looking for
do they come and see to you what's your
preference or they say listen shut up um
we're going to find some for you how do
it I want know how it work it depends on
the family yeah cuz every house is the
same 100% like like my family it was
will'll find people someone you know and
like UK girls are not good and um my mom
thought like need someone from back home
because I she's going to leave you
eventually it's like they know the
future understand so it has to be
someone from home and then when your mom
gives you an ultimate yeah Mom or a girl
a girl says to you your mom or your or
me or cuz I'm the oldest in my family so
my mom wants me to stay with her so
she's so worried that she's going to be
alone cuz my father recently died about
six seven months ago my grandmother died
I knows this she's mom's
bit yeah you know you know what it is
I'm not making excuses for Bengali
parents Happ way they do but the way
they were B up it's so toxic they're
more accepting of marriages cuz they
don't have the benefit of choice like we
do they understand they they had
marriages out of love there's no love
for the person right they do out of
necessity to carry you know the family
name or just to unite V Etc there's so
many and also I was going to say it's
like a there's like a entitl like
there's entitlement involved so what my
mom would say is I gave birth to you
yeah um so and I raised you so you have
to marry I choose and if you don't then
I don't accept there's emotional
blackmailing 100% a lot of it like and
then and then there's like a lot of
victim mentality as well so they
victimize themselves and then you feel
guilty by but you want to also be cuz at
the end of the day when you marry
someone you're going to be living with
them not your mom and you have to see
that person every day and if if you're
not you're not happy with the choice
you're going to be miserable and they
don't understand that they just want
it's also like a status thing as well
this a very very much status driven what
are people going to say but our you know
the the generation has to change that
how do you guys go about changing that
so you guys are the new generation how
do you guys go about you know what we
need to put an end to this but putting
an end to this doesn't mean we are
disobedient to our parents because it is
it is a sin do you get it so we need to
be very very careful these are these are
mother our parents that brought us up
that doesn't mean they can do whatever
they like with us however it has to be
done in a certain conduct you what I'm
trying to say understand what you're
saying um but you know when you said
being I get what you're saying about dis
being disobedient to your parents is a
sin but if it's if it if it's
Disobedience against Allah then you know
that know yeah so if islamically I can
marry someone outside of my culture as
long as they are a good Muslim good
character good good uh conduct then I
don't see why I cannot marry this person
just because they're not Bengali with
with with parents there's a balance of
disobedience and you know respect
basically she to forc you to marry
someone you don't want her islamically
that's wrong there's no such thing you
can't force someone into marriage right
so I think with with Bengali parents you
need to sort of put your foot down right
you need to sort of stick up for
yourself yeah and as as a man right they
can't force you to marry who you don't
want to I I think I'm learning that as
well like I'm learning to be kind of
Stand My Ground but also like with a
balance of like respect where I'm not
Crossing that boundary of where now I'm
disrespecting my woman cuz it's just
learning that balance and I'm not going
to lie it was a struggle but I found it
interesting so okay so yes Emma I was
going to say um I agree with what
brother maty said um Case by case it
differs and I think lot of the
discussions going to be that culture
clashes with our Dean basically and to
answer your question I grew up in a
cultural family but alhamdulillah as I
became practicing uh to through wisdom
uh you know educate my parents it was
wisdom at first as you know when you get
a bit zealous in the beginning a bit
hardcore um then you realize that
they've been conditioned in the way they
grew up yes and it's about understanding
from their perspective but at the same
time um educating them and making them
understand I look Islam says this is
wrong and also explain look if this
marriage goes ahead and you're forcing
me if it doesn't work out whose fault is
it you understand and also other things
um balies do is they have to marry in
order of siblings and again that's
changing now alhamdulillah but um so if
the eldest isn't married yet then the
young person who probably have found a
good prospect that person has to wait um
has to be in order alhamdulillah
recently one of my cousins broke that
tradition and it was good so I think
there's basically the dean saves us all
ultimately you know when you bring the
dean and you educate people and for me
time and time again I used to ask my
parents what are we are we balis are we
Bali Muslims are Muslims do you see I
make them think critically and then they
realize you know what we're actually lot
of Hindu culture yeah not just culture
things like um touching the feet on the
yeah basically um you know how culture
you you go down sorry on we used to we
used to go up to aunties uncles all the
elders we used to bow down and tou their
sayam three times yeah yeah yeah yeah on
their
feet
basically you you go down on your knees
yeah and you have your hands like touch
their feet Sal long time and only in the
last 10 years I'd say Bengali s's
question I saying what what are we doing
that's that's it's a Hindu thing yeah
but just want to say Qui just on your
point with um getting married in order
there is a reason for that I'm not
saying I agree with it but women in
Bengali culture they have an expiration
date they do that's what that's what
Bengali people teach like you know when
you get to 30 oh but your kids you you
need to have kids before 25 before 30
that's why they try and marry them off
like at a younger age like an order for
I'm not saying I agree at all I'm just
saying that's what the uh yeah sorry
guys you can speak just whisper cuz it
pick up forgive me you can speak she
wanted to add something to you know the
Bowing of the feet thing yes um
interestingly I I I think me and my
sister said that um the moment of Eid
when we're supposed to bow down and like
touch her feet we said no actually I'm
not going to do it she got so offended
so offended um who got offended my mom
so we said no you didn't do it to her
yeah yeah we didn't do it so we kind of
broke out of it um and her wrong her
reaction kind of obviously it makes
sense but she felt violated she felt
like we were disrespecting her by not
touching her
feet so so is yeah but it's like like
you
know you know what is with with with
that though like we could have explained
that to her like oh uh like we don't
want to do it like we didn't know that
she was did you explain islamically that
it's incorrect so what brother said oh
okay I did say that to my mom I said
like the Islamic perspective we should
but that's what it is we need to start
you know our parents cuz they're own
fashioned cultured from Bangladesh we
need to like engage them in an
educational perspective tell them why
it's wrong tell them why it's right I
completely agree with you well again
it's Case by case but for me I can tell
my parents alhamdulillah I can tell them
like Mom this is wrong like you can't
say this you can't do this she'll be
like okay you know what like I'll show
her vers of the Quran hadiths reliable
had she'll understand what I was saying
like um this probably um crosses over
different
cultures um but I'm talking about this
this mindset and I've seen it a lot
where bongol is had his mindset let's
say um there's you know a sister needs
to get married right she may not be
ready for marriage like mentally
emotionally um all that kind of stuff
and a lot of parents have this mindset
marriage will fix her so basically throw
in the deep end okay and it's Lally like
sink or swim and that again comes from
the other generation they had to sink or
swim m some of them made it
alhamdulillah they basically empowered
themselves they was that good
daughter-in-law but what happens when
they don't swing they sing the guy
basically realizes I married someone
who's basically had trauma hasn't healed
um doesn't know the different gender
roles and then he ends up in in divorce
but this mindset needs to stop where
marriage will fix her and um uh for
example
my what my situation but uh the person I
married was the first proposal so I
understand sometimes okay it's a good
proposal you want to get to go ahead but
then they don't think long term that
this person you can't accept the first
proposal like so she didn't know like
she's going to get married or no
discussion took place and that is
another issue where there's no
communication with some parents and
children but you sit them down and the
whole thing about what you looking for
are you are you ready to get married
someone's like you're ready to get
married they assume but I think it's
that mindset they needs to change where
you know um they're not ready for
marriage but yeah marriage will fix them
kind of thing it's a very silly mindset
it's interesting it's like it's like
they thinking for you we need to break
the cycle that's why we're here the
children of these people yeah they came
to this so when I say when you when
you're talking about specifically
breaking the cycle we're talking
specifically like you know each like
before two people come together in
marriage cuz we complete one another we
don't like you're not my entire
happiness because then if you're relying
uh relying on that one person for your
entire happiness it's going to become
very toxic like rely uh you know we you
know we're always rely on Allah nothing
should come above Allah but like you
know well you know with my brother my
oldest brother he broke the cycle in our
family and alhamdulillah I have it so
good if I like someone out of
my C I can I can get married to them
easily because of my big because he
married someone that he he was fond of
in University and alhamdulillah he had
to break that but I remember
how you know don't want to name any
names but it was a toxic Environ he was
very hard for yeah yeah yeah yeah so
let's let's dive let's dive into that
topic then since we're talking about
getting married let's dive into topic of
interracial marriages um
so like as far as I know from my
experience um cuz like when I was um
getting to like trying to get married um
I can remember specifically it's it's
actually my marriage documentary itic
about my journey yeah and I I mentioned
this stuff I just mentioned everything
that I went through literally while went
through I just mentioned how I dealt
with it how I felt I can remember
um I went to East Lon mosque and I just
I'm not trying to blast East Lon mosque
they do amazing alhamdulillah I love
them is you know like the work they're
doing for the community the Masid
amazing um someone told me there's a
marriage under you know we need go the
section upstairs so I went I was a new
Muslim I think it was
2013 or 2014 so I went upstairs and I
went into this room and then the brother
was like IAM he thought I was in the
wrong place and I was I'm looking to get
married basically
I just wanted to I think they had a um
list of people or something like that so
I went and you know what he said to me
he goes oh no this is only for
bis yeah well I'm I'm a jing I went I
was sat there he was looking so c yeah
he he was he seemed like a he didn't
seem like he was a brother who was like
born here but he literally out right
said to me ah we have here in bis we
want to marry Bolis and and in my head I
was thinking I I don't I I didn't know
what to make out of it but put that
aside this is this this is like this is
what really happened and to me I don't
really I'm not really I don't all
hostility I'm like okay look it's like
that but I can remember like in certain
instances I think it was one or two
occasion I was getting to know Bol
sister for marriage um one of them it
was very pleasant like um straight away
said you can speak to my dad uh you know
it didn't work out but one of them there
was there was this issue where like and
it's it's like oh my gosh you're going
to marry outside he's not one of us like
they were so immersed in what the
community would think are people going
to say now this me myself like I look a
little bit Asian yeah okay I think so I
look B Pakistani because of my nose yeah
probably so the the issue here is by and
thus there's nothing wrong with the no
yeah yes anyway so the point is this
year is that I realized with the
pakistanis it wasn't that bad when I was
getting to know pakistanis for marriage
it wasn't that bad like I was invited to
the house I was SP I spoke the father
would be another room you know we'll be
like it was but I found in bongon that
there's extreme level of like broke deep
and like that's my experience so how do
you guys deal with this when it comes to
interation Mar that's interesting I was
going to say you know I feel like the
younger generation are like I I see a
lot a lot more interracial like
marriages like with bengalis and other
like races but within the younger
generation I see a lot especially on
social media you SE I think you know
what it is with very normal so like it's
interesting that he said that let just
say something before I forget this yeah
go ahead closer yeah it's it's you know
when he said the um Pakistani the house
he went went and he was supposed to be
better there's balii families as well
will accept you course do you understand
it's just it's just that family what it
is in our culture what they say is like
just after day my auntie goes I said
look um I'm going to look outside the
culture as well outside of she goes no
no no don't I heard a lot of cases um
Bengali people marrying outside the
culture and um it breaking up I said
aunti I married into my culture look
what
happened she's saying oh I know this
person got married to this
and they divc now this that so it will
happen to me as well do you understand
but we all have
different it's somewhat true though it's
somewhat true like when no no in a sense
where when you when you have two
cultures oh sorry do you want do you
want to finish what you're saying first
you go ahead go ahead I'll let you
finish first I don't want use M up yet
yeah yeah do you want to finish what you
said no go ahead you do okay um I was
going to say when you have two cultures
merging it's really difficult to like
maintain one you know both at the same
level
know I you I to Mom outside mythity as
Muslim mom said she'd prefer a Bengali
girl purely because she can't speak
English and it's easier to like relate
to someone connect everything do you
know what I mean I don't think it come
from a racist Point as much as it did
before yeah but there is as you said
before there is color can also say like
sometimes get there there's two extremes
so some people have the mindset they
want to marry boli culture just to prove
a point that's also wrong and I agree
with what the mat said basically like
even Scholars say if you can marry
within your your tribe it's
compatibility that's preference but to
prove a point and I get it it's so nice
you know interracial marriages but you
got to think about everything not just
to proove a point and alhamd say within
my family I got you know people who aren
married pakistanis reverts um but like
it will change slowly but at the same
time there nothing wrong with marrying
from your own kind of culture course to
me
marriage about two two families don't
forget yeah that's true you're marrying
into the two families the thing is
preference is okay like someone can say
I prefer yeah the issue here is though I
I I didn't sense preference it was more
like like this is from the theme like no
you cannot it's like it's Haram yeah and
that is where the problem Aris and this
happened it wasn't with bengalis it
happened to be with the somalis it
happen be with arrian so the thing is
here is that it's it's a form of I don't
know if you say racism but this is
what's wrong somebody can say I prefer
that's my daughter son marries or my son
marries come preference is fine but the
moment you start blackmailing the moment
you start saying what's people going to
say Etc what was Allah have you ever
thought what's Allah going to say like I
see with lot of these issues people are
more concerned about what people would
say rather than what Allah would say
this means people people commit Zena bro
there's no excuse for it by the way
there's no excuse nobody make an excuse
that oh my parents there's zero excuses
cuz I've been in situation where it's
gone Peak as a young man in this living
in this country bro but Zena is never an
option do you get I'm trying saying say
so people should have make an excuse and
like oh yeah I went to my parents and
they said no so um I'm going to go no no
no no there is no excuse but we need to
understand that at the end of the day
that preference is fine but BR outright
racism or outright they're going to
think have you ever thought what what
are you going to question Allah for
stopping your daughter to marry a black
brother a white brother whatever brother
it may be as long as he's practicing
what you going to say to Allah on day of
judgment when if she ends up fooling and
all because of what what's my culture
going to think and I have heard of a
story I don't know exactly where it was
from but there was a black brother who
proposed to him I don't know if it was
bongolia or Pakistani Asian I don't know
and they rejected it they rejected him
because he is black yeah and this is a
story that's been told to me yeah is
that she ended up falling it didn't
happen with him she ended up committing
with a non-muslim man and became
pregnant and to me it's like you know
what I'm so sorry you deserve that it
might sound harsh you have rejected what
Allah has stipulated like the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him said if a
righteous man comes to ask for your
daughter's hand and if you reject it
there will be F in the land so the
problem is what you rejected it because
you're too concerned about what others
will think it's good as seeing Allah or
the community
community I'm
not one thing I say I think everyone
will hate this word for passion is this
term called
yeah else can I
say same basically it means what would
the people say how would you how do you
change that to what would Allah say
um that's the one
so
say I need to
say yeah I can I add to what you just
said you don't have a long beard you
don't have a you're not a scholar
you brother I just wanted to add to what
you were saying what were you talking
about that International marriages
racism what people would say you know
yeah I was going to say you know that's
largely to do with the fact that um like
our parents grew in a very obviously
cultural like background but I feel like
they don't know who God is they don't
know who Allah is cuz for example my mom
like she reads the Quran but she doesn't
know anything uh uh she doesn't know the
English trans she doesn't know the
translation of what Allah is basically
trying to tell us in the Quran so how
it's it's going to be really hard for
them to like break out of that mindset
if they don't know who Allah is um and
they won't be conscious of Allah when
they're making these decisions or when
they're stopping their kids from making
these decisions but you you can break
that you need to like 100% but you know
I feel like you need to educate her 100%
but you know with my mom my mom it's a
little bit different cuz she's like
she's some some people will want to be
educated that's a problem there's a lot
of stubborn it it's hard though I you
heard of I I get what you're saying
but I was going to say with my mom it
turns into like a massive argument mat
has one and a half minute to speak
without being interrupted yeah uh a
whole minute and a half starting now now
I was just going to say with like with
Bengali parents as well it can be really
difficult to educate them imagine you
were telling your dad a 50 60y old man
now dad what you're doing is wrong he's
going to think who are you to tell me
what I'm doing I'll be doing it my whole
life you're 20 what you're talking about
you know what I mean it's so hard to
educate your parents again Case by casee
basis alhamd my parents are easy to talk
to but I know a lot of what the parents
on right so it's just it's really tricky
to get through to them even if you show
them evidence you know material from the
Quran from the Hadith it's very very
tricky they're so like stubborn in the
head they don't want to like understand
that they're in the wrong but what
you're right once you've broken that
then they'll start realizing oh maybe
I've been doing it wrong maybe I've not
been you know um faithful to the Quran
for example religion but it it takes a
lot of effort to do that I've seen so
many situations where Bengali children
were kicked out of the houses where they
been threatened physically and mentally
do you know what I mean so it's very you
sort of have to balance it you don't
know where you are until talk to I
understand what you're saying I'm done
so I'm GNA ask you a question are you
Muslim yeah so you have to you have to
educate your parents no matter if they
don't want to hear it you have to be
consistent with it inshah one day Allah
Allah will open their heart and they'll
realize you have to be persistent and at
the point of what what what if there's
physical abuse involves you're still
supposed to tell them after you get
physically I I agree with what you're
saying 100%
yeah in the physical abuse why what I
would say is at the end of the day
mental health is a very important thing
yeah and we've got young kids in in the
house and it's it's difficult for them
to watch you and the the mom arguing and
that's going to be traumatic for them
and but you don't but but you don't know
that you don't know it can heat up
andent physical violence then I would I
then I would stop speaking I would be
quite mindful of a child being in the
room but I'm trying to educate my mom
that doesn't know anything you can be
mindful but what if like maybe it's not
a child maybe it's just your siblings
the worst people to give da is to your
parents the worst hardest people not the
worst sorry it is it it's the hardest it
it is hard I think it you're not going
to try you know I hear you you know you
know what it is it is a f fine line
because here we don't want it to turn
into where we have kids were watching
this and be like yeah I can say this you
cannot you they has to obedience to your
and father but obviously not at the cost
of them telling you to do something
against your religion I think you need
to deal with it in a certain way like
you need to understand I come from a re
family and my dad is hostile like I talk
about this and I don't believe my dad is
malicious I don't believe my dad hates
me my dad just wants the best for me and
he he fears that this religion is
whatever whatever for that matter even
with my dad and you need to understand
yeah you guys are talking about
intercial marriages I get attacked for
praying Salah I have to tiptoe to do W
so the thing is here is like I asked a
question like my mom even asked my
dad when he were like you know have a go
at me and what what's this guy doing to
you he he just wants to pray like but
the point is this to me I'll be like
come on like I'm absolutely what am I
doing it's all bad to you but the point
is you need to understand there's a way
and conduct of dealing with this kind of
stuff um and and to me when I was in
these situations where let's say I was
getting no for marriage and she said my
family doesn't want it I would say look
listen there's two options here because
at the end of the day the family's are
marrying did you get it I don't want to
be hostile with my in-laws so I would
say listen try to be gentle try to and
let me be honest my dad will cuss me
sometimes over like Islam and sometimes
I will go and kiss him on the head yeah
bro I've never seen him so disarmed in
my life him with kind exactly I've never
seen my dad throw this arm when he would
cuss me out you know he would he would
he' be he'd be watching Bin Laden and
he' be like hey come come your friends
are yeah that's what he say to me he's
he's like come come look he's like your
friends on TV yeah so and to me like I
would show I once went to him and just
kissed him on the head and said look
crazy I said dad you know I said I love
you regardless and I've never seen him
so disarm in my life so there's a way of
going about it we don't want to be
Rebellion Reb because at the end of the
day you need to understand it is
important like they are our jna so it's
a very thin line so I'm not trying to
encourage anyone here to go on a mad one
with their parents like yeah I wish I
that was B please W there has to be
utmost respect to parents there has to
be a way of dealing with it and number
three for Allah all things are possible
yes yes AB this is a test and ask Allah
to help you Allah can change their heart
yeah so I'm saying there's a way of
dealing with it and I agree that to
certain point but yes if it is that you
are now being blackmailed you are being
threatened you being kicked out this is
V now and even then a certain manner but
again there it gives no right to anybody
to raise their voice to their parents it
gives no right for you to be
disrespectful you can communicate and
say mom that is wrong or dad that is
wrong so I would say do that any other
points because I'm going to go to the
point of marriage I want to know how you
guys do your weddings after just just
quickly there are also parents out there
where if you and your about this topic
if you want to take on a second wife
they'll dis you yeah come to that topic
don't worry I got man I'm we're come to
in the B culture So speaking about U
yeah speaking about emotional blackmail
speak about pressurizing they will tell
you you get married again you're going
to be disowned I don't care BR as long
as Allah owns me I will stand in front
of Allah and say did that commit no I
don't care if the entire Globe this owns
I I would say this is what one one
scholar said as well yeah is even like
topic like this when you speak to your
parents maybe best not engage with them
because they because of you as a means
they might
stay they might like oh I don't agree
with it so don't even entertain a
conversation with your because like said
don't tell the people what they're ready
to hear you want them to disbelieve in
Allah and his messenger so we have to be
careful but this issue of like since
you've opened issue polygamy yeah guy's
ey didn't open it he opened it yeah I'm
just here entertaining it um how do you
guys how's the Bol culture deal with
polygamy so you're saying basically for
you guys it's outright you it we know we
not for the sisters it's yeah but I
don't know anybody in my family that's
been in that situation I think it's
frowned upon cuz like um like uh my I
guess my dad he got like a second wife
but the problem is he even though he got
second wife back home he neglected his
first wife and his kids and that was the
the and I I understand why my mom would
get resentment out of that why she would
view like um like having multiple wives
as a like a negative thing because you
you got another wife but you neglected
me and my kids I think Comm in our
culture in this culture in this country
sorry it's not I don't know anyone any
uncles or anything I've married like
multiple women but in Bangladesh i' say
you see it around every now and then
it's not maybe like you know high but
it's still more common than it is here
it's probably secret second one is
secret third or fourth but I was going
to say you know you know with like
getting a second or third wife I I just
don't believe that South Asian men have
the ability to treat each wife
equally because tell you why because I
think men will we go a lot of looks
right we got a lot of looks so if we
have if we have two women and we see
one's prety than the other one's doing
something better than the other we're
going to value that woman over the other
one I just think South Asian men they
just don't have mindset but Islam Islam
gives the stipulation though because at
the end there's a Hadith of the Prophet
Muhammad wasallam he said that if a man
has two wives and he inclines one
towards the other he will come under
their judgment his body leaning on one
side and to do on someone oppression
it's it's a big it's it's it going to be
accounted for so men have to be very
they need to understand J aside is that
to oppress like just go to a different
topic I don't want to go person that
with your father is that if if this was
to happen there's going to be
accountability because at the end of the
day you know you have to give the rights
you know that's the reason why if you
think about it I always say this
polygamy was sent down to protect your
rights because as men we are prone
polygamy and Men usually do it by Sid
chicks mises and girlfriends so Islam
allowed polygamy so when it is going to
be done it's not done in the at the cost
of the second and third wife being used
and abused so Islam sends these
protocols to say if you're going to do
it you have to do it the right way you
speak to the father you get married you
do a wiim you look after her you provide
for her so when a man looks at the he's
looking at this and thinking I have to
do all of that I've changed my mind do
you see how it protects you and do you
get what I'm trying to say so if you
look at polygamy even though woman hate
it it's actually sent down to protect
you guys because you know you guys are
high pergament by nature and I'll be
honest with you I've seen this phenomena
where a lot of women will be like if
they're the first wife over their dead
body you get a second wife by the way
I'm not against no no I'm saying you are
I'm saying you are but when they don't
mind being a second wife I've seen this
bro it's it's you see it like you know
can you clarify the you mentioned if
your heart is inclined towards one you
wanton be simp equality if you're not
yeah yes yes yeah but if your heart is
inclined to one wife than the other then
you you won't be held accountable
because of course you can never because
Allah says in the you can never be just
talk about Justice look it can like
we're talking about looking it might be
in his heart that he has a specific
liking to the other one you don't need
to tell the other one about that it's
between you and her you get it but to
mistreat and favor and oh this is more
hikma brother oh my first wife done this
or this is this is ridiculous like you
need to understand a woman's emotions
have some emotional intelligence that's
very key as well you know you know
brother Al I've seen you speak a lot
about polygamy and there's nothing wrong
with I see a lot of wisdom and hikma
behind it but the thing is the type of
like there's a lot of men out there who
are not equipped no I'm not even talking
financially I'm talking mentally otally
like their emotionally is especially
emot understand how um how a woman's
emotion works like if a woman is getting
emotional and you're getting upset at
her rather than trying to understand her
trying to come situation you know
they're saying if one person is fire the
other person needs to be water but
you're you're you're like doubling up on
the fire yeah then like most I feel like
most of them like don't understand that
so if a woman is getting emotional
they'll they'll get you know they'll get
this is what you said here is H sister
is very it's so fundamental remind when
a woman came and at the time and was
saying you know why the woman asking for
and and the woman came and said
basically know this Allah has given us
the H said the woman is right and um I
am wrong and I'm saying the same thing
here sister you're right and if I've I
don't think I've said that but in this
matter I'll be wrong if I if I've said
that you're very Tri because at the end
of the day we as men we if we're leaders
we cannot be emotional like you we need
to understand you and a lot of men are
not with this knowledge do you get it oh
why you getting upset she's going to get
she's going to get upset the best of the
woman has smashed the plate just imagine
bro you're chilling with your boys yeah
your wife comes and smashes the play in
front of everyone brother your ego will
be so hurt the prophet he didn't even
get angry you know what he said he said
your mother got upset and smiled which
man can do that bro so you need to be
equipped with that but if you if there
is a man like that in like if he's
married to Bali if there is a man like
that are you willing to accept that
because come say oh if he's like this
but believe me when that man comes along
they still not happy like what sorry
like the way you said he's got emotional
intelligence financially can provide
I'll be okay with it like if you are you
sure sister because because we will not
be we will not be men like that right
now cuz you know some people contact me
some let me let me say like I you know
it's something that I never really
agreed with because I I never understood
it because I like every time someone
would mention it I would have this
feeling in me like a like I don't like
that feeling uh but then I I guess one
day Allah gave me the wisdom and I
deeply thought about it and I thought
about how Allah created the men and how
Allah created the women how men uh you
know they're able to impregnate women
like multiple times you know throughout
the year whereas a woman can only get
pregnant once a year you know the
biology and everything and I and then I
understood like this is and then Allah
saying like like women are actually a
fit like not a f like a struggle what do
you call it struggle for men biggest
weakness and Allah like Allah is saying
that like that your biggest weakness is
women regard whether you're married or
not so I really thought about then I
contemplated on I was like so if Allah
is telling me that then and I don't I
don't know cuz I don't we think so
differently like as a man you think
differently I think so differently uh so
I understood that and I thought there's
hikma behind it there and this this is
probably most likely an actual need like
for men to uh to be married to to more
than one wife you know there's a lot of
men also who are okay with like having
one wife but there's I I would say
majority majority I challenge I
challenge any man to come here and tell
me that they're not maity actually okay
okay we got to challenge you know you
know things like that I personally I
can't do I can't deal with more than one
wife do you know what I mean if I get
married once I'm exception my brother my
brother mat at least St trying to
convince
St tell me tell me what you just said I
said I couldn't deal with having more
than one wife okay you said you said you
cannot deal okay why are you saying deal
because I just don't think I think I
love the emotional buties my my emotions
I won't be ready for it okay M I love
you for the sake of Allah yeah I'm going
to give you a scenario there are two
sisters I don't know what your type is
by the way yeah so keep it in your head
women yeah know one specific women yeah
there there's different kind of women
yeah so imagine in your head yeah you've
got two beautiful
women woman of tawa Praise good woman
they both come to you and say we would
like you to marry us Islamic Etc and
they are both very
attractive woman of TAA practicing Etc
can you tell me why you would reject one
of them I just I just want genuinely ask
me I don't want to make a point I don't
want to make an evil thing genuinely I'm
just asking you because what happens is
when you come and say this woman and go
to their husband see there is one guy
out there now if there are two beautiful
women I look I'm a married man my wife
is a co-producer of this I talk about
pgy all day some of their KN man in the
house after Dodge yeah okay my life
might be at risk but the point is what
that I have to be honest with myself so
two beautiful woman bro why would you
say no Tom So when you say two beautiful
women they're exactly the same
everything right okay but there's
between if I see two beautiful women
here now there's going to be some sort
of difference where I'll think the other
one's better than the other I'll go with
that one then no that's fine but I'm
saying to you that if the other one
doesn't have a great deficiency I'm I'm
not talking about someone you have a
liking both yeah yeah as a man as a man
what would your heart say they both
agree with you
both F there's no there's no he if both
of them are woman of T why would you say
what would you as a human as a man what
would go through your mind would you not
be like to have both of them in my life
hell yeah why would you say hell no I've
just told you about the emotional
intelligence I couldn't handle it what
this sister said what this sister said
about having the emotional like ability
to put up with like arguments and stuff
being the calm one I would have that for
two people I can't do it it's going to
be mentally what if those two sisters
say we swear by Allah get winess sign a
contract we will not give you an
emotional headache we be chilled out
that's not realistic though if that was
the
case just speak the speak the truth
speak the truth you know are you
specifically talking imag okay one one
second this is very important because
anytime Brothers mentions they mention
headache the first wife would say put
those all those factors to a side as a
man you would want more than one woman
any man unless he's um you know
you know what I'm saying but but what
I'm saying is like in a nutshell that
you will have the innate desire we're
born like that you get what I'm trying
to
say that in a desire right so I know
you're for like um
marrying I know Islam Islam says that as
well what I'm saying is like I think I
Haven done a lot of research on this but
I think is more appropriate at the time
of when there was War when the sahab
right now I don't I don't think I don't
think the Point South Asian men no but
that's what I'm saying let get toi I'm
talking to it's a specific no but I am a
South Asian no understand but I don't we
can't generalize all of them what I'm
saying is though no man would say no put
the headache to the side in no man in
his right mind would say no to two
beautiful
women why would I say no to two
beautiful women and I am born and I have
the incl the propensity to be polygamous
and they have the propensity where the
hyp you're a handsome brother yeah Mah
so I'm seeing bro no no let's be honest
here it's and woman they don't mind
sharing I'll be honest with you and
unless factors to it so why would you
say no to CH no headaches
involved all right if there were no
headaches involved then welcome to
welcome to may Allah bless
you okay the point the point I'm just
seeing is this yeah we are hardwired and
and it's the headache Factor because a
lot of brothers say oh if my first wife
didn't give a headache so you would but
what puts you off is the first wife
that's listen listen to listen to what
you just said yeah it's it's about the
emotional intelligence that's what men
are lacking I believe polygamy I think
it's a beautiful thing and I think if
you can treat each wife the same you
can't Allah says in the Quran you can
and you can never be just try to try to
so if you can try to alhamdulillah we'll
have a better
generation I'm just curious the lacking
of emotional intelligence quickly say St
cuz I don't want to make it I was going
to say I'm just curious you know U you
know the polygamy thing you're saying
every man is driven uh to want more than
one woman okay I get that um is what are
they driven by are they driven by intim
the idea of intimacy it can it can it
can be Intimacy in Islam I'm just
curious It's like this to look in Islam
yeah look at the end of the day like you
said there's many factors to this yeah
there are more women than men yeah uh
more men are in prison more men die so
there's so many factors that's my hand
as well and not only that though for a
man he could he could be married and
this is where we don't understand for
you guys the moment you fall out fall
out of love with your husband you do not
want to stay with him and want to
divorce and move move on yeah we don't
think like you yeah for us it's like
this I love my wife we love our wives we
have no problem and I've said this
before if they put me a lie detect the
test and they said to me do you love
your wife I'll say yes they'll say pass
would you die for her yes pass do you
want a second wife yes pass this is
where you guys don't understand us
because
us you guys think I get that I would
stay I would stay with my husband even
if I fall out but that's that's a
sacrifice yeah that's what I've been
taught by my ancestors that's good
sister that's good but what I'm saying
is the reason I say this by the way is
because I see so many brothers who are
going through oppression they don't see
their kids they've being oppressed
they've been accused of All Sorts
because their
honorable husband has gone and do it the
right way that's why I'm so obsessed
about Le it's not because Ali's obsessed
that's A Private Matter between me and
my wife did you get it nothing to do
with anybody the reason why I'm so
adamantly speaking about this over and
over again because if you knew the
stories that I know of good brothers who
want to get married again all hell
breaks loose the point I'm seeing is
this though it's not personal we don't
do it because we we want to hurt our
wives but we we are programmed in a way
that we could love our wives and want to
another woman it does not mean we don't
love them you guys don't think like that
but we do anyways we can we need to move
on cuz I don't want to make a discussion
can you guys tell me a bit about the
Bengali wedding so for example how's it
work I know you guys are on this Ferrari
Bentley and all kind of stuff going
around can you tell me this a part of
the buali culture but the thing is how
do your weddings go how many weddings do
you have H
imagine so can you guys run me through
two people have met two two people have
met yeah um and how ises it initiated
who comes to whose house before before
we get to that you can start that off
yeah I want to take you a little bit
back uh B culture there's one thing
missed out what it is uh what we go for
is if the skin color it's not it's
nothing to do racism whoever's the
lightest I know know but the they think
they think it's not racism so you know
that it's nothing with Africa or
anything like that if you're bengoli and
you're dark skinned they'll say oh she's
too dark she's no you understand this is
a big big issue in our culture that if
you're boli you're Muslim you're from
the same Village and you're dark she
will have low chances of getting married
oh she's dark she's too dark it's
basically the same as saying like oh
she's a big problem black um skin sorry
now go on forget African and foret say
you know everything you're saying is
exactly like obviously we're sisters but
we're completely different shades and I
am darker skinned and my mom said that
you know everything you just said she's
everything she said to me like you're
darker than your sisters and you won't
really be able to get married like no
one's going to want you um so you need
to work on your skills of like cooking
and cleaning and taking care of the the
man I grew up genuinely thinking like
she Al she also told me like you know
Allah cursed you with this skin color so
I genuinely grew up thinking that but
obviously I I grew out of it okay look
may Allah preserve you mom may Allah
bless you this this can be not knowing
do you hear what I'm trying to say but
but this is this this is this is a lack
of you see all of our issues and
problems tie back toed this is a l of
lack of yeah believe me sister I don't
care what color you are if Allah WR
that's going to marry you you're going
to get married do you get it so anyone
that's watching this what color you are
how you look W As Long as You observe
Allah's laws and legislation Allah will
send somebody to your door just
understand this and it seems to me this
whole Bengali thing of I think it's
coming from an older generation where
Hindu Hinduism is I think I think that's
culture that like really Mak exactly
exactly so any any any sister that's
watching this who might have a infer
complex of their looks their color uh
their ability whatever all I'm going to
say is W Allah is the creator of the
heavens and the Earth it is not
difficult for Allah to find someone for
you just look at your relationship
between you and Allah being obedient to
him and giv his right and W believe me
Allah will send someone to you and
ignore anyone that's making you feel
insecure question so um others elaborate
on things you sp about the cars and
everything but from my
experience few un Islamic practices is
when the Mah is discussed the bride and
the groom aren't even in the discussion
it's the elders that discuss it yeah UNC
they're not even consulted so the bride
and the groom they're not even consulted
they're not even in a discussion for the
Mah the ERS they customer normally the
dad or the uncle they sit and then the
dad will and then the dad will inform
you and her dad will inform her yeah
this is what what we agreed whereas the
system might be okay with I don't know
HUD or something like that but they're
not even in the discussion yeah and the
other thing I'll would say is um again
it's so bad but um Bangladesh that as
well but after the M thing like if you
have potential sister-in-laws
brother-in-laws you meant to joke with
them oh my days that infuriates me so
but but again as in it's emphasized
basically this is your sorry yeah like
this is your like sister-in-law like
she'll banter with him blah blah
basically it's just outright flirty it's
proper FLIR so they take his like shoe
this and that they're like I've seen
I've seen stuff their shoe and run away
with it they'll chase them down brother
I've seen who's taking his
shoe take the groom his potential
sister-in-law so his potential wife
sister they'll have Next Level banter
and that kind Behavior take his
shoe for the I've seenu on Tik Tok where
they're physically like wrestling and
stuff mental is it like for culture that
for example when you're going to the
bride's house somebody locks the door
and you need to give money to open the
door is it like
that true it's sometimes it's worse as
as I grew up and I came across a Hadith
that your in-laws are
death said your brother-in-law is like
death exactly yes well I've heard so
many stories of like Bengali like um
getting with their like R law system all
this and that it's mental it's actually
cra that's because of the you know how
that starts as well I've got people that
I know friends and stuff that have done
this they're falling in love with like
other the other side of the family and
stuff because there's flirting stuff
going on messaging each other all this
Tik Tok like social media and stuff
because what they want to do is they
want to record themselves like flirting
and stuff and making jokes put on social
media bangs views that's it I encourag
that is crazy man it just shows us how
much Co Islam and culture and and and I
did see this strongly like I'm like look
look there we're not seeing every single
B Etc you get it there like but yeah
like it's it's it's sading and inshah
you guys can change this that's this
generation slowly changes this can you
tell me about the wieding I want to know
about the the the proposal the first
time of proposal can you guys please run
with I want to know from A to B because
we're running out of time I don't I
don't know fully about this but all I
know is um the fish ceremony oh my god
do you want to explain it so basically
that that one I'll go real quick if you
want yeah go ahead so basically what it
is is like let's say you set settled on
a spouse right you found someone want to
marry you inform the parents they have
like a phone call and they'll have
something called which means a meat sort
of thing where they speak about like Mah
like everything like when the wedding is
how much gold to give then you go with
like something called an engagement
party a few months down the line next
year um is it yeah cine fan sorry yeah
cine fan and um and then cinan is the
engagement party that's what it is
there's like four different parties you
m then you do a nikah this is a few days
before the marriage isah you're leaving
something out do the you know what
you're leaving out the negotiations
that's that's at the you know the
negotiations you literally
negotiate money land what you're going
to
give the mer this that we're going to
spend this much minimum in the wedding
the hall has to be this big the food has
to be five that's when both families
meet basically they do the if you not
marriage can break you know and also one
thing they bankrupt you can bankrupt
yourself you know actually statistically
true right the higher Maha for a woman
is that's I think you said this actually
that show that the more you spend on a
on a wedding this this why nonm Muslims
by the way when Allah and his Messengers
say it nobody believes it when a cafir
non-muslim guy comes and says we've done
a study they go oh you see it's
unbelievable the insult that we give to
Allah is unbeli colonial mindset brother
the brainwashing that so so so so okay
so then what what you guys do in the
wedding like how many dresses do a woman
have to wear what does the guy have to
wear please tell me a bit more amount of
money SP this one um so
so um there like obviously the wedding
the H the Hanah
and it's the meny first meny party I'm
I'm not going to lie to you I I have no
idea basically when I got married I just
got married in the mosque I'm not
married anymore but when I got married I
got married in the mosque and I just did
a simple nicar so I don't I'm not
familiar with like all the okay so go
ahead
we first start off with negotiations how
much is going to be spent and then it's
cine fan which is the engagement and
then after that we have the meni which
is like a hen Hindu stuff it's
like you apply hen on the you guys from
rice is that from the is that yeah there
is stuff like that there is stuff like
that I think we do the H the what's it
called hly the little dust and all that
stuff like a uh you know them platters
of there thr up in it
yeah that's a very seen that I've seen
seen we didn't do that in our Temple I
haven't seen that but a lot of Hindu
stuff goes on you'll be shocked my
father stopped going to weddings my
father literally uh upset so many family
members because he don't tolerate No
More he said I can't tolerate this
there's no segregation there's no um
nothing to do with Islam so at weddings
they'll do like um musical instruments
like Bollywood music stuff like that
they do like daners and stuff the groom
and bride will sometimes dance together
as well I've seen that on Tik Tok it's
crazy is it um so it's proper like
Indian but I have seen a lot of like
Bengali doing just a Nik in a mosque um
you know it's just easier isn't it and
financially affordable so there's like
two ways I'm going about essentially but
you know what Bengali weddings I looked
at the average is 55 60k on average for
Bengal That's not including maharo gold
prices by the way if I marry if I marry
and I spend s to the Grand here I'm
never divorced that woman in my life
yeah but she'll divorce you bro the
statistic no no no but that's that's but
that's interesting cuz the thing is if
the Mah is that much yeah this is what
Islam deals because Islam protects you
number one Islam is so beautiful alhamd
for Islam the best thing that ever
happened in my life is Islam just think
about it yeah if a man has ill
intentions the fact that he has to speak
to the father and give Mah is something
that protects you guys yeah because if
he has ill intentions so and if the
woman has ill intention she's a gold it
also protects me because if she
initiates she has to give me back the
Mah or part of the so you see how Islam
protects both sides for Islam I was
going to mention one thing you guys
forgot you know um I've seen this a lot
I've never done it my mom's always
mentioned it like she saved up a lot of
money just in case for for that reason
but um it's the fact that the bride's
side gives like Mah to the the the man's
side they buy the furniture I never so
basically that is purely obviously
cultural
Islamic yeah so so it happens at my
cousin's weddings everywhere so what
they do is like the agreements and the
negotiations are like this how much you
pay this how much you pay for the
bride's dress Etc right and then they'll
give like gifts and then pay for the
suit for the wedding Etc small stuff
like that which islamically it's not
encourag that it's not even said to do
that is it yeah yeah um this is in Hindu
tradition yeah yeah exactly yeah but
they're buying like Furnitures and
everything with with they'll buy like
cars and stuff sometimes with with
wedding for the grou they exch my bought
car for my sister's husband was M yeah
you know you know don't get any idea
mared balii
sisters you trust me you can't handle
balii sisters man they're mental some of
them I tell you that much no I'm joking
I'm joking cut that out cut please keep
that in alhamdulillah listen do you know
why don't get any ideas guys my my my
brother-in-law is a
Quran he's paying for his kids private
Islamic school so so alhamdulillah my
dad saw his qualities and that's why my
dad did that that's what you call a man
do you understand that's what you he is
the way he's bringing up his
kids
is Quran is's learning hads huh BNA
means a nephew oh okay yeah my sister's
daughter I somebody's name sister son so
basically and look at that look at look
at that's why my father saw a quality in
in that's what you need because when you
die your wedding your cars you this it's
gone imagine having a a son-in-law who's
encouraging your kids to we don't they
don't care about
they don't care if somebody came and
said yeah they don't even ask him do you
pray what what do you what do what what
job do you have how much do you but guys
quickly we need to wrap up because we
need to speak about number one um
marital disputes how you guys did with
marital disputes yeah I just want to say
before my because my brother La will
watch this I'm not I don't I don't want
to praise in front of him no you should
he's you know what my on my dad's death
my my my uh dad said to my
brother-in-law you're the oldest you
look after these a lot like a older
brother so he's doing so much Subhan
Allah without him bro I would I'm the
oldest next oldest he's doing so much
for us it's unbelievable you understand
may Allah bless him and his family J
understand he did so much because you
know my situation it gave me so much
trauma I literally got off marriage and
stuff you understand because look
without nothing I got a tag on me
because in Bengali culture if you're
married and you're finished you got a
tag on you it's like look frowned upon I
didn't even want to yeah this is the
other issue no yeah I built a separate
house I didn't want to get into I built
a separate house in my house in the
garden I built a separate house so I can
have a separate uh private time like a
guest house yeah like a guest house so I
don't want to get into mortgage or
anything like that I planned and then
this happened this was this got dropped
on me and my situation it happened so so
quick like I said it was done like
within six seven days and it came she
was here I didn't even spend one minute
with her literally and I don't blame her
she's a good girl look I want to make
this clear because if they watch this I
one thing I want to say she's very quiet
she's a good girl I don't blame her at
all she blames me because she said it to
me she blames me it's not your fault but
I can't explain it to her because my
language and her language we don't she
can't she don't even understand me and
she blames me but I just want to say I
don't blame her and it's a of Allah and
I'm sorry what happened I wish I could
go back in time it's not your fault and
I could erase this and it's not your fa
you know hope it's a lesson to be how do
you guys deal with um marital disputes
so in your culture if there's marital
disput does the family in-laws get
involved straight away um does like like
how how does it work I want to know from
my experience um again from what the
kids have seen from their parents they
could also be conditions they have this
I call it B mentality like everything
has to be with families get involved
every building you know family sit down
um and unfortunately I've yet to see a
amicable divorce take place where people
stre colors come out one divorced place
so one family wants to diss the other
one and uh spread rumors that yeah they
were the problem so uh again cultural
thing don't follow the them don't back
by don't slander unfortunately gets very
messy really yeah so if you guys like
imagine like a couple you guys have a
marital dispute do you get your in-laws
involved they get they stay away because
like certain cultes like the somal
culture they the in-laws usually say
listen just you guys deal with it
yourself Etc so they they they
discourage you know trying to get
involved is it the same with you guys no
tell us please can tell us gets involved
like the parents will get inv involved
the siblings will get involved that's it
Nots outside families getting involved
as well it depends on Case by case basis
usually with with Bengali Bengali
culture depends how bad the dispute is
like if it's a divorce dispute it
usually goes to the parents or the
Elders of the community
Village get involved basically yeah
basically a lot of people get involved
and the problem with that is like it's
always one-sided if you know let's say I
get married right and I want to divorce
my wife if I tell my parents about we
have like a little intervention right
it's going to be one-sided for me Isn't
it do you know I mean saying oh she's in
the wrong this and that it's never
amicable this brother's right I've never
seen a Bengali divorce happen like in
okay maners it's always been like I'd
say the what you g to say like so um uh
when when I was married uh uh my in-laws
weren't involved because my ex-husband
was basically an orphan it was just my
mom and if I but if I would ever come to
her and tell her like we're having this
dispute she would always blame me she'
say like what are you doing like are you
cooking for him are you cleaning are you
like making sure that he's okay I'm like
no like he's actually in the wrong like
but she wouldn't understand that she she
would be like just bear it just bear it
just tolerate it uh and won ever like
come to a point of like divorce cuz what
are people going to say and but then I'm
telling about I'm miserable I'm
depressed in this marriage I don't I
don't want to be in this because he's
he's not giving me my rights she's like
it do matter do Mar you've made your
choice cuz I kind of I married outside
of my culture she it was like a it was
really difficult but um she was like you
Cho you basically chose to marry outside
of your culture you made that decision
so you're going to have to put up with
it cuz if you get a divorce
um people people are you know people
what are people going to say
basically basically um so it's really M
would always always blame me like you're
not doing mindset where once you married
him slave B once you're married you're
set for life basically and there's kids
involved like you're almost like forced
to stay that marriage however toxic it
is and sometimes the other generation
don't understand that it's actually more
toxic for the children to witness a
toxic relationship so once kids involved
it's like no you got to stay in this M
for the sake of the kids you know there
is like we had G Roman we talked about
this as well it is good to a certain
extent that divorce is not something
that is accepted that easily it is good
because in today's time what's happening
for the most ridiculous reasons were
crazy so it's good that you have it but
I think it's toxic with with it become
toxic because yes it should be
discouraged but it is allow ISL we have
other extreme where it's like yeah and
you have a little dispute yeah divorce
people so yeah people nowadays though
like South Asians they'll get divorced
over the litest thing you're right
there's two extremes where like you know
there could be physical abuse abuse
involved but the other side like oh like
he's not giving me what I want or she's
not giving me what I want oh divorce
that's get something better the problem
in this generation is we have too much
options there's so much options that's
why divorce is so frequent you know what
I mean I can also say I've yet to see
again when I say divorce take place
properly like the proper procedure
there's a reason why Allah has given us
three divorce right yes so one talak
have separation time to think give it
three four months and then more often
than not they both realize that they
they miss each other right getting
didn't get married again but go through
the full process say you've given your
best shot usually after the first that's
it's over the guy moves on but then he
realizes he's got feelings for for his
ex so and so forth everything's rushed
nothing's like taken
time sorry I'll say one thing as well I
don't think I've come across it's very
rare for me to see like the old
generation of Bengali being happily
married and it's that's how bad it is
like from my personal experience might
be different but like generally the
mother and like Father they're not
actually in love with each other yeah
yeah like it's actually when you think
about it it's crazy right um this is
trauma for yeah we see that we think
okay is a marriage supposed to be like
is an example is this the example of
marriage I'm not going to say who like
but like friends and stuff like I've
seen like you know their parents just
don't love each other they care for each
other they do the Necessities but Choice
yeah yeah no exactly but but what I'm
saying is like the old generation the
divorce rates are lower it's because
they tolerate each other whereas a
younger generation they know at the same
time they might think they know their
worth so they need to divorce do you
know what I mean it's It's Tricky cuz
the thing is I do admire that like to an
extent where it's like they are very
like the thing is that we have this
attitude that like yes love should be
there nobody should oppress other but J
it's not just about that there's also
Mercy Allah talks about you know to one
another you know you need to understand
if the C diminishes where's the rahma so
the thing is there's an ay in the Quran
talks about this so it's not we have
this Disneyland Hollywood thing where
like it has to be it doesn't that's not
the reality and we teachers real think
that this is a reality now this doesn't
mean you are harsh to your wife Etc but
it might be point where you've married
for 15 20 years of course you're going
to come and just you know every time I
love you Etc it's it it it it doesn't
happen it should happen but that
shouldn't be a reason of divorce and we
live at a time I call it Amazon Prime
Flex which is I bought it from Amazon it
comes I don't like it I'll send it back
and we carry this attitude to our
friends our uh uh family relationships
even our spouses I don't like something
I send you back but I was going to say
generally I feel like um I don't know
maybe I'm speaking from like a biased
point of view I do feel like women do
like they don't want to in our culture
they don't want to get that divorce
because I was like that as well I didn't
want to get divorced even though I was
super like depressed in that marriage I
didn't want to get divorced because I I
was like oh my God I'm going to be a
divorce in society like what are people
going to say
I'm never going to be able to like yeah
so that's why a lot of women like like
in our culture specifically stay within
the marriage uh even I I think generally
in a marriage women are more trapped
than men right I mean men's the they've
got the financial sort of stability to
divorce the women specifically in our
culture speaking in our culture yeah
more so than if I can I really agree
with what you're saying I think there's
two extremes where um divorce is you
know um taken too easily and then at the
same time a lot of Tolerance it's about
the the middle ground there's a lot of
qualities to we admire from the
generation the whole thing about it
takes a village to raise a child yeah
that's forgotten um things like you know
tolerance and making an effort giving it
time what has forgotten it's just like
said this
Amazon yeah there's good things and bad
things you know I think I think that's a
good points and negative points there is
a good quality move on with the times
because the thing is here cuz statistics
show that and we've know from our Dean
that woman initiate divorce if it was up
to you guys you guys would divorce US
every day uh that's that's I mean it
makes sense cuz we are like exactly so
that's the reason why I think the the
dynamic kind of works I'm not talking
about the toxic level but the dynamic of
divorce being frown Works in a sense
where and this is what gabri Roman said
which I agree to a certain point not
that if you're in a abusive marriage
where the guy is hitting you not giving
you rights that's a different Islam has
giving you a right to get divorc however
we're living at a time where people are
initiating divorce for the most
ridiculous reasons so that stigma is
Good from that perspective
that the fact that it's frowned upon and
that you guys need to think about it yes
because if you guys are more prone to
initiate it it's good that you have some
sort of a concern of if I do but not to
the level where you're abused and you're
rights are violated that you stay in
there I'm not talking about that it
makes you I think it keeps woman females
in check in that aspect because that is
your
weakness I get what you're saying I kind
of yeah I get what you're saying but
there's also it comes down to emotional
intelligence on the woman's ch um like
sorry lost my chain of talk he was going
to say something no okay I have to don't
I can I went to a talk once well like it
I literally went blank and I was looking
I was looking at everyone and I didn't
know I didn't I said guys I'm I don't
know I don't know what I'm talking about
I totally forgot everything so it
happens but one thing one thing that
I'll recommend everybody here is well do
your do your morning and evening I'm
telling you because I never used to do
it and Shan attacks in different ways
yeah so if you remember let us know s
and it's totally normal trust me
happened happened to M remember M yeah
Mich is what happen so it's totally
normal quickly say it right now CU we're
end in about a couple minutes we've got
to basically what I want to say is my
mom when I know what she did for me I
know she had all the good intentions in
the world yeah she did not do this to
like hurt me or anything like that I
know that she did it for my benefit I
don't blame her uh like that at all um I
know she blames me because for ending it
but I know inside my mom did this for me
she thought it would be she thought she
knew what is best for me not not I what
I know what his best I she didn't I
don't know why she didn't let me choose
do you understand she she said you you
had enough time so that's it it's like I
had an expiration dat you're getting old
uh no one's going to accept you you're
the oldest in the family and things like
that so basically I know I'm going back
a little bit because cuz look if my mom
sees this I want her to know clearly I
know she did this for my benefit and I
don't blame her I don't blame her and uh
yeah you know the I know how much you
love your mom trust me aun yeah he's
been in the house he knows my mom my dad
he's been to my dad's janaza he knows
everything so he knows anyway yeah okay
guys we need to wrap up because we was
going to talk about the divorce we
talked about divorce how it's initiated
um and just in a nutshell um when it
comes to divorce you guys just what two
families talk
and what do they is there anything that
we're missing in the culture that they
implement cuz they were talking about oh
you have to give us this land or that
land is that what happens to divorces so
so you can't get divorce until you give
some kind of money your land why is this
a bank
bro I say specifically with divorces the
land has to be split that's not common
is it so let's say if I marry a wife
marry someone right and um let's say
some land has been passed down from my
dad to me when I'm divorcing um that
person I don't have to give her a l like
what's the Bengali approach I don't
think you have I don't think you'd have
to give but she will ask for it right I
see yeah would you say that's a a common
issue is that a common issue right I'm
family member of mine has actually
experienced that yeah okay I think any
last words we need to wrap up just
quickly like you know all these like
discussions of relationships divorce and
stuff no one speaks about the ultimate
goal Jenna so and it's is like you know
my rights his rights this life is short
man like you know have a bit of
Tolerance get through it unless as you
said it's a really bad abusive
relationship F you know get people
involved in and go your separate ways
but no one speaks about the ultimate
goal and because the lack of that just
like get up and leave like yeah that's
that's the thing that the prophet said
Nations will come together and why
because Allah will take the fear out of
the enemies from their heart and put the
love of the Dy and that's what it is bro
how many people are driven of Jenna
we're going to we want to enter Jenna
that's not even a factor and when that's
not a factor bro if you don't have as
your goal your goal is going to be what
D your calculations and decisions are
going to be based on the D I just
remember
sorry I just remembered what let's go
good thing so I was I was talking you
you was talking because I've seen you
mention it on your podcast a lot where
uh you were saying statistics say that
women are more likely to Dev divor
divorce the husband and I get where
you're coming from because from the
point of the fact that we are emotional
being but I was also going to say it
it's it comes down to like emotional
intelligence on the woman's part like
let's say your husband stole something
to upset you you talk to yourself like
what am I upset about is this necessary
is it necessary for me to like you know
blow it out of proportion so it's down
to the woman and yeah I was going to say
also marriage is is it's not based on
love it's based on a commitment just
like Salah sometimes we don't feel our
Salah sometimes we don't feel that
connection with Allah but we continue to
pray because we make that commitment to
Allah and it's like that in your
marriage like if I had to like compare
it to a relationship it's me me and my
sister like we we have arguments and
disputes here and there but we always
come together and we you know we saw it
out we make that commitment to each
other that no matter what the situation
is whether we argue whether we we've
said something to hurt somebody uh
either either of us we come together and
we solve it because I'm committed to you
regardless of um regardless of whatever
and it's the same with any relationship
in your life whether that's marriage or
your relationship with your family or
your sister specifically also a Rel with
if feel a relationship with Allah you're
committed it doesn't matter if you don't
feel it you're committed and that's what
that's what it is it's it's you know um
you want say saying yeah
just yeah I was just going to say I
think we' seen too many times in this
like generation people think love is
everything love isn't everything just
cuz you love a girl or a guy if they're
not practicing what does it matter love
isn't anything like we grew up watching
a lot of Bollywood movies but even even
now even now like the whole thing we
seen in social media is like oh like you
know love is the most important thing
else can be worth them most important
thing is finding someone who's
practicing or at least wants to practice
love is a secondary thing compared to
everyone else forget about how rich that
person is it's about what they have in
their heart for Islam you know that's
what I go based off you know I feel like
eventually love grows anyway throughout
the marriage it's true it's true look as
long as there's not hatred yeah and what
you define is love what what the hell is
love I come home with bloody balloons
and flowers every day is not always just
like see that's what I'm saying what is
it like for nobody knows no can even put
they're chasing something they don't
know what it is there has to be
sacrificed like looking after you know
like the prophet wasallam said the one
who looks after two daughters and bring
them up Etc where is the aim of doing
that I'm I'm I don't love her therefore
I'm going to leave her actually the
whole dynamic of the marriage her your
kids are you kidding me you're going to
leave her because of oh I don't love her
anymore social media as well it's
crazy Med
couples good parts and the negative
parts we talked about that respon
we' done a video about this can I add
one last thing quickly sister pleas I
think the root cause of majority divor
is you're not educating these young men
and women about how a marriage works
you're educating both genders completely
don't worry sister that's the reason why
I'm I'm working on an app because of
this and Allah subh is my
witness like the reason because you know
why because people do not know the
Dynamics the reason do you know this
show has helped me so much in my
marriage cuz I understand from a most
perspective and I'm like wow I never
I've been doing something wrong in my
house and I incorporate and change that
bro it helps me and insh you guys at
home it helps you and the aim is that we
want to help people into the marriage
seeking process and marriage itself
because we don't understand each other's
Dynamics they're a whole different we
whole different being exactly exactly so
inshallah brothers and sisters our aim
with this show is exactly this we don't
want marriages to end we want marriages
to work inshallah uh divorce is of
course Halal but it comes with
consequences so
it helped you guys at home like I
learned so many things about the balii
culture and like we said before we're
not seeing every single balies like this
that b as a whole but there's a lot of
things to be work and it shows the lack
ofed us going back to Islam and that's
it brother and sisters may Allah bless
our B brothers and sisters for coming
here I've learned a lot and may Allah
bless you guys at home inah till next
time brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bread or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing de that you want to do but
we turn it into a moneymaking machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of true s I
myself will be donating for that
inshallah click the link below and
donate may Allah subhana bless and
preserve you guys we will together insh
see the day when Palestine will be
free